15 million that many data records were
exposed worldwide via data breaches and
that's just for the third quarter of
2022. don't want to be next right then
remember the basic rules of cyber
hygiene never list your bank card if you
need to pay for something get multiple
ebank cards and turn off overdrafts on
them top up your cards when you need
them to make a purchase don't use your
email address to sign up for sites you
don't trust always create a new email
account setup forwarding which
automatically redirects emails to your
main mailbox if the service asks you to
create control questions to recover your
password come up with your own control
question if that's not possible use
answers that can't be found on your
social networks update your operating
system and applications regularly stop
using the same password on different
resources it's better that your
passwords are never repeated use a
password manager to store them always
enable two-factor authentication if
possible never click on suspicious links
even if they come from people you know